at the top of the show I do my direct
message where I give my feelings of the
week and I wrote my a little piece about
it yesterday and then right after I
wrote it I watched your TED talk and
basically your TED talk was a twenty
minute sort of much broader version of
exactly what I happened to write about
yesterday by by total coincidence and I
know that the things that you talk about
are the things that I'm incredibly
passionate about and that I've made this
show that so you had a great quote in
your in your TED talk you said that
FEMEN is a movement that is trying to
rebuild society without permission I
love that line so can you just expand on
that a little bit and what made you
start feminine and where do you think
it's going well particularly about that
statement I should say that anyone who
is dreaming to rebuild the world should
count that you know you should not ask
for permission because nobody will ever
give it to you so if you dream to change
something you should not ask for
permission or weight when someone will
give you that waiting a long time right
and it will never happen yes because
well in Ukraine as I said we started in
Ukraine movement in 2008 where exist the
movement already exist for eight years
and I should say that's when we started
we didn't have any particular knowledge
of you know political knowledge or
didn't know how to work with media I
told you already that we didn't really
have a clear understanding what feminism
is about and I don't feel embarrassed or
shy to say about that because I think
that this should show and reflect the
society in which we were growing up I
remember joining this little group about
which nobody knew at that moment yet we
were young and we had a meeting in a
very Soviet style the cafe in the center
of Kiev sharing two cups of tea on 54 15
of us because we were all young students
coming from small cities to Kiev
dreaming that this will be the time that
the
place where we will have his women
opportunities and the only opportunities
were proposed even in this big city in
capital that looked for us you know huge
tremendous place we we only had
opportunities well similar to those that
I saw opportunities that women had in my
childhood you know to serve someone and
of course very often Ukrainian women are
because many claim that they are
beautiful but what is true they are not
educated and poor and this becomes a
reason to involve easily involve women
and sexual exploitation prostitution and
of course you know on my way to
university everyday I I could be here
first of all harassed second receive
many flyers from well pimps or brothers
who would propose you to go to work and
many women many girls did go and you
know applied for such a job because you
don't have other possibilities because
you're not anything else so for us the
first reason to start our activity was
to fight this disease this illness of
Eastern Europe considering women as sex
slaves as prostitute and we were
campaigning against prostitution and sex
tourism which is really widespread
disease in Ukraine particularly and we
were campaigning against that wearing
pink clothes and carrying pink balloons
and pink flags believing that with this
pink colors we will attract attention to
to this problem however of course we
failed and organizing protests with
100-200 female activists and nobody was
even stopping when they were passing by
to read our banners and we were in
search of tactics of the ways how we can
attract attention of this very a
political again desperate society to
something very essential to the rights
of women something that the whole world
is already talking about accepting
changing you know adopting laws and
yeah well for two years we we were in
this desperate search and in 2010 we saw
that the situation in Ukraine was
changing because the dictator which we
understood later dictator Yanukovych was
elected as a president and the situation
was changed you could immediately feel
the censorship in media you could
immediately feel the change of political
situation and the mood in the country
and we understood that we probably have
to go as a female activist as female
voices will probably have to campaign
about some something broader something
that brings us to this problem you know
more limited problems such as
prostitution and sex tourism something
that is you know to the root of the
problem the political situation to the
economical situation those people who
bring the society in such state so we
did our first topless protests 2010 to
be honest it was more as an experiment
it was also sort of a scream from inside
and as I said it was it was you know a
decision made during this you know being
in a very in a desperate search of how
to let people hear women's voices and
their problems how did that first moment
feel for you when you did the topless
protests because you guys even if it
hadn't picked up much traction you were
already talking about things as you've
said that we're sort of not accepted in
your society so you're already going
against the grain but then yeah you
realized all right we've got to do
something that's gonna really get us
publicity the right way and all that how
did literally that first moment when you
took off your top feel because we had a
huge discussion in them in the group
well sort of in a fight about whether to
do it or not
because and I was one of those who were
against topless protests so that came
later for me but definitely it had a
huge effect because we now we're not
only
the unpopular speech but we also used
and very unpopular tactic we were
showing something any age of a woman
which is very unpopular in this society
the image of woman which was popular in
Ukraine was the you know a nice smiling
sexy cleaning lady but we were showing a
screaming and greet bare breasted woman
was the message was slogan written
across her chest which was something
that was breaking completely the
definition you know they they yeah the
definition or imagination the the
context in which people could see the
woman and the definition of woman in
generally in Ukraine and of course it
was it attract a lot of attention
different attention as well as some
support there is no support from Ukraine
and of course we felt a huge support
from abroad and a lot of criticism of
course of course we will be named
prostitutes immediately because we were
naked which again revealed something
that for people you know naked were
human is equal to prostitute and
actually I should say that so is this
topless protests what we are reaching I
think that we are committing sort of a
test for democracy we commit tests we
test the society and with this tactic
with the messages and speeches that we
have we test society and we reveal a lot
we reveal a lot on the reaction on those
protests so I should say that what we
actually do very often people say famine
are violent because we are aggressive
because we are screaming so which
immediately feel it for people you know
a woman who is angry is the violence is
something violent we you find to see
angry man but well woman which is not
smiling or keeping silent but who
screaming is something violent we got
out there they're guilty people well we
probably kill you
we're probably feeling some people buy
our messages I mean of course literally
we do not harm who do not we do not
interact you know we we don't touch
anyone physically we can touch and
attack ideas we buy our ideas but what
actually do is we appear take off our
top and strip our ID is written on our
bodies we create I think that we
transform our bodies in the political
messages in our manifesto in posters if
you want this these are our posters on
which we write our slogans and I think
this way we I think it's kind of general
a few functions because first function
of course is to provoke to attract
attention second is that we change the
meaning of what naked body if it's not
you know you there's so many you can see
women naked women everywhere on covers
of magazines and billboards
the opposing smiling the sexy what we
are showing we are showing woman who's
not sexy but you know she's political
her body's political she's not smiling
she's screaming she's not inviting you
to use her she's refusing she's showing
her anger she's showing that she's
demanding something and of course this
is something that breaks a lot of
stereotypes and rules and traditions in
particularly in society like Ukraine now
generally in many countries we received
a very different reaction of such
protests and I think it reveals there a
lot it mirrors a lot well what's
interesting is you're really talking
about the true roots of what feminism
really is you are demanding to be
accepted as an absolute equal to a man
which really is what first wave feminism
here in the West was it's now changed
and morphed into something else but all
you're demanding sort of is equality
I've seen you described as a sex
streamis do you like that word do you
guys you've used that word a little bit
but I've heard it about you more well
this is the word that we created
actually and weird if I were selfish sex
tree mists
because we use our sex the fact that
we're female as our weapon our bodies
are our weapons and I think this is also
sort of an odd answer to fundamentalist
to terrorists who use the gun hunts who
actually kill people we show them our my
body is my weapon because first of all
you are scared of it as if it was
actually a weapon which could kill you
and a second we see that this body
really can destroy you know can destroy
bad ideas or at least challenge them or
provoke them and create discussions so
yes we call ourselves extremists because
we use our sex sex as our weapon our
bodies our weapon okay so as I mentioned
at the top of the show and as you've
illustrated here quite obviously it's
not just that you talk about these
things but you literally are putting
your life on the line I mean just by
taking your shirt off the amount of
people who you've angered it's it's
incredible it's crazy but you've also
had very close brushes with the law with
actual terrorism and violence can you go
into a couple examples the KGB example
in Belarus and just and and you were
literally an event that you were
speaking about free speech was shot up
and there's some crazy audio of that can
you just talk about those two examples
well yes I think I think this is what I
was talking about that will reveal a lot
of things with this protest but to be
honest we didn't expect that we will you
know just a topless woman with the words
written across her chest could you know
could invite the governments and secret
services to change them arrest them
kidnap them and torture we have been
literally tortured in Belarus after one
of our protests that we staged in
December 2011 which was an anniversary
it was 19 December 2011 anniversary of a
one-year anniversary of a huge
demonstration in Minsk where during
which many people have been arrested
mainly disappeared and some reportedly
have been killed but the information is
always hidden there and we staged an
ironical protest mocking dictator Luke
Jenko in front of KGB office which is
officially official KGB service there
and during the protest journalists have
been grabbed by the stuff
KGB staff the man who came out of the
office of KGB and we we were ignored so
we could leave the place they certainly
knew that today we'll be able to catch
us before the what was important at that
moment for them to stop the journalists
from releasing the images however some
journalists managed to do it they left
before having experience obviously
working in Belarus and later a few hours
after when we were at the bus station in
Minsk on our way back to Kiev to Ukraine
we have been grabbed and thrown into a
bus in which we spend the whole night
being questioned by men well we saw
their faces they didn't hide themselves
but they were clearly saying that their
KGB and they were asking us who paid us
for this protest they were saying that
would they know that Europe pays us
which is ridiculous you know who is
Europe I was trying to ask them as well
they didn't answer because they were the
ones asking questions so yeah and after
that night we have been brought to a
forest in which we changed their buses
we were taking in another bus and there
there was another troop of men faces of
who we couldn't see anymore because they
were plastic handcuffs on our hands and
we were not allowed to move and had to
keep our heads down and looking on the
floor well we heard during I think 5/6
hours drive we heard that we will be
killed we heard the description you know
different description of how we can be
killed and we were asked to breathe loud
because they wanted to hear us breathing
saying that in few hours we will not be
able to breathe they were saying that
they will send our corpse or parts of
our bodies to our mothers
so on and so forth which was of course
the done very professionally you know
you could feel that this man do this
every day is their job actually to
torture people like that um we received
a few hits but they were not beating us
severely but later we were taking out of
the bus in a forest and there they were
they were doing horrible things such as
putting you know gasoline on us and
playing very you know coming with a fire
very close to the body so you feel like
you would they will burn you alive right
now yeah they made us undress you know
what turn and so they were creating
situations when you feel like next
second they will rape you they will burn
you they will kill you they will cut you
you know what they did they cut my hair
was nice they were you know they throw
some you know green antiseptic in my
face which I couldn't wash away you know
like things that were somehow would at
some point would sound it's ridiculous
but it was it was torture it was
psychological and physical torture they
were filming everything on two video
cameras so it was supposed to be
reported to someone and we so 15 men
around us and masks and the fact that
they were wearing masks made me think
that they will not kill us because they
hide their faces however I didn't know
how far they will go in their action and
they after this torture they throw us
out of the forest and we spent another
five hours six hours to find someone and
we found a village a village it's a big
word probably for seven houses you know
in the middle of the forest we found and
we were lucky enough that at that moment
there was someone who came from the city
and had mobile phone and of course for
24 hours already all at least
russian-speaking world was searching for
us and information was spread everywhere
and we easily contacted our colleagues
and journalists and
later four hours later the ambassador of
ukraine arrived to police station which
we were staying for some time and took
us back to Kiev well this is one of the
experience you know in Ukraine also we
constantly were followed by Secret
Service's threatened and well they
opened for criminal cases against us for
hooliganism this is something that they
use in Ukrainian Russia against
political activists for example right
now there was a artist dr. Polanski who
burned the door of Russian Secret
Service and he's also written as a
hooligan while they treat us as a
hooligans because this is something very
very you know you write good you could
call anyone who leaked and yeah and in
Ukraine after our first and loud protest
against union of church and state I had
to flee I had to leave the country
because well literally I had to jump out
from the window of my apartment jump in
the car and run away um when this stuff
is happened to I mean I know you can you
have so many examples of this which we
could you know we could spend hours
talking about but when these things have
happened to you I mean what happened to
you in that farce it sounds horrific you
survived but obviously their goal is
intimidation their goal of course is to
silence you and then by silencing you
they silence your followers and that's
how they they end you guys they don't
have to actually kill you so I'm curious
afterwards after something like that
happens
do you or did you feel alright maybe
we've taken this as far as it should go
me or did it did you immediately double
down and say now we're we're getting
somewhere with this play a superhero and
of course you have all the fear you feel
you feel that I will not
right after you feel I will never do it
again
but then
you know after some time thinking about
it and really spending time on repeating
in your mind what really happened you
understand that it's not it's not us who
went too far is their reaction goes too
far probably because we do something
which they don't want to happen and so
it means that we do something very right
and I think of course again I will never
deny that we have fear we do have fear
but I should say that the fear of the
fear of giving up to those people is
much bigger than fear of being taken to
the forest at least you already know how
it feels and what it is and again your
fear it's a choice right so we probably
make a choice you know not to fear but
to do to deal with the fear and to
continue the activity because again just
think about how ridiculous actually this
all is there are girls who take off
their tops and write slogans and for
that they are taking to the forest
KGB staff are spending with them 24
hours torturing them and doing all the
insane things how ridiculous this is how
ridiculous is the fact that there are
people planning terrorist attacks taking
guns blowing themselves up because they
want to stop those who draw a card
caricatures you know who drove us very
funny or not funny for some cartoons but
something so peaceful so somehow very
childish as well you know something very
simple so I think that it also reveals a
lot it shows how it shows them yeah how
crippled our society is how the how we
we replace the fight or the yeah the
fights of ideas by actually divided
between people and I think that this is
a pretty reason to continue and you know
sometimes people say well you already do
it for six years and you are only 25 and
you already have been nearly killed at
least three times but what makes you go
on but this actually this is
exactly the reason that make you go go
on because you understand that just
because you say you know you write three
words in your body or you write an
article or you draw a cartoon they want
to kill you for that isn't it ridiculous
doesn't it show that I live in six
society and because I don't want to live
in six society I continue I go on I know
that the history of my time is written
right now and well to let fundamentalist
dictators misogynist to write history of
my time well I don't agree with that